researchers at foundation site 202 were
going about their day as they would
normally or as normal as a day could be
in the scp foundation if anything
normality was abnormal for them it was a
quiet day at site 202 as it had been for
a few weeks to the distress of many of
the researchers stationed at the site no
anomalies had breached containment in
the past 20 days there were no random
anomalous events to investigate testing
was up to date for all anomalies they
had contained in the past few months and
their leads on potential anomalies had
run dry there was little to do at site
202 and its researchers grew restless as
the piles and piles of boring foundation
paperwork grew even taller that was
until a fateful day in the spring of
1990. it was march 22nd the cold winter
weather had still lingered in the air
that day but it was warming up for all
the people living around the site there
was word that a school not too far from
scp-202 was experiencing an event that
could only be described as potentially
catastrophic to the scp foundation's
reality of the researchers at site 202
five were deemed suitable to form a
temporary task force the first dr j
alfred henry a senior researcher who was
a former member of the mobile task force
the mole rats during the investigation
into scp-1730
the interdimensional site 13 dr henry
also brought along his assistant
researcher tyler zeissman the next
member was yvonne olek who was in charge
of taking care of any living anomalies
that may be present at the location
another member of this team was
spriggand firestarter a former member of
the anomalous group of interest the
serpent's hand which specializes in
magic and spell casting this project was
overseen by samantha streisand the
director of site 202. the team was not
given a normal designation as most task
forces are a greek letter and a number
instead they were called the taint team
and were in charge of documenting and
combating any and all parts of reality
that were tainted by the anomaly the
team set out for the location of this
potential anomaly along with their
standard issue firearms and tactical
armor they were armed with the portable
scranton reality anchors and possibly
the most important part of their arsenal
their expertise the location the taint
team arrived at was nothing they were
expecting from what they had heard about
past reality altering anomalies they
were greeted with a single school
building it was large in size more a
castle than a school it was constructed
out of red bricks with the roofs being
slanted and white in the center of the
building complex was a large clock tower
the researchers commented how similar it
looked to a nearby church and continued
inside they moved throughout the school
looking around for any sign of
abnormalities there were three floors
and two wings but all of them housed no
anomaly the portable scranton reality
anchors each member of the taint team
held were not picking up on any levels
of reality instability they were close
to calling the investigation a false
positive and moved back to site 202 when
a faint beeping noise was heard from all
the members of personnel dr olek was the
only one not to react to the sound out
of the team it's just a meets processing
plan he said sternly there's nothing
here except empty rooms and thus let's
just head back the rest of the team was
confused a meat processing plant they
were all briefed numerous times that
this was a school olek was the first one
to comment that he recognized the
location was this the reality altering
anomaly they were looking for a school
that made people think it's a meat
processing plant that wouldn't be the
weirdest anomaly the foundation has
found one side had a yeti working for
them but this was rather underwhelming
what do you mean a meat processing plant
inquired dr henry whatever let's just go
olek responded coldly dr henry stopped
him as he turned and looked into his
portable reality anchor there was a rise
in humes on the other side of the main
corridor on the first floor humes are a
unit of reality stability baseline
reality is located at a hume level of
zero anything or anyone with a hume
level greater than that is able to
affect reality in various ways the team
moved slowly to the other side of this
room once again finding nothing except
the white drywall and tile flooring of
the building there was one odd element
as they approached this portion though a
door it was not like any of the heavy
steel doors the team had seen in the
building it was wooden like the one
you'd see on a house the hume raider
skyrocketed it was a number they had
never seen before
4 000 humes after a 10 second of looking
at each other on what their next move
should be dr henry slowly reached his
hand out to the door and twisted the
bronze handle as the rest of the team
drew their weapons he opened it quickly
finding nothing but a dusty staircase
the hume reader plummeted back to normal
levels as quickly as it had spiked the
team discussed what they should do next
they decided to enter the basement level
which they found was not listed on the
floor plan of the building dr olek
insisted however that he remembered this
meat processing plant having a basement
they moved into the dark stairway and
slowly progressed down the stairs it was
an oddly short staircase that led to an
oddly small room the team was once again
confused why did the hume level hit a
record high if there was nothing but a
small boiler and a few pipes snaking out
onto the walls dr olek was notably
absent from the team after some
searching he was found a bit up the
flight of stairs frozen in place with
fear yvonne dr henry called what's wrong
there was no response as dr olek just
stood there frozen in shock then
suddenly the silent doctor began to walk
down the steps almost robotically his
eyes were locked onto the boiler but it
didn't look like anything was wrong with
it to the eyes of everyone else dr olek
entered the room with the rest of the
team and moved towards the boiler you
don't see it olek said the
veins what are you talking about dr
henry responded there's nothing wrong
here researcher zeissman moved towards
dr olek in an attempt to calm him down
as he approached dr oluk became hostile
and began fighting the researcher the
other members of the taint team
attempted to calm and restrain the
doctor but olek thwarted these attempts
and moved to the corner blood holy crime
he wants blood
lot
a lot of blood dr henry began
frantically radioing director streisand
in an attempt to get more help but as he
did olek cried out the word blood
another time a gunshot rang out his body
fell to the ground but his blood did not
the blood of dr olek began flowing up
the walls in a jagged pattern then began
to absorb into the concrete suddenly the
hume level spiked in the room and the
blaring alarms of the portable reality
anchors were all that could be heard the
room switched in appearance attached to
all four walls on the basement were
hundreds of long thick veins they were
red and black and purple and dripped a
syrupy liquid of the same color onto the
ground it was almost a foot of the
liquid in the room which the agents had
been standing in without even knowing it
there was a mass slithering towards the
corpse of dr olek it was black and a
deep red in color it almost looked like
a person but it didn't move or act like
one
the entity absorbed the body of dr olick
into its central mass and began moving
towards the remaining members of the
tink team the foundation personnel
yelled into the walkies that they needed
to be evacuated immediately they
sprinted up the stairs toward the roof
and out of the building just as they
reached the rooftop they heard a
terrifying guttural rumbling voice
mutter the word
their reality anchors hume readers then
plummeted back to normal levels and a
foundation helicopter arrived to
evacuate them from the rooftop the
foundation would designate this anomaly
as scp-5633
they devised a number of containment
procedures to combat the anomaly site
202 was to be used as a drainage
facility for the anomaly secretions and
all personnel who enter the basement of
scp-5633
must not have a phobia of blood as with
most anomalies the scp foundation
personnel of site 202 decided to conduct
testing under the belief that
scp-5633 could speak to them again
blood used for transfusions at the
foundation was transported from site-17
for the taint team to use as bait to
attempt an interview it has been over a
month since the taint team had been to
scp-5633
they remained with three members despite
losing one to the anomaly as they were
all familiar enough with the building dr
henry placed down a bag of blood and
readied his reality anchor immediately
the blood was drained out of the bag and
began to flow up the walls of the
basement as hume level spiked the room
revealed its true form the humanoid
entity responded i am glad you know what
to do
another bag was placed down
you are now part of my creation
it was decided that two bags would be
placed next dr henry believed that more
blood would potentially get a greater
result you should follow every
instruction i give you
you should give me blood each time or i
will stop giving you instructions
another two bags of blood were placed
down but this time no phrase was given
from scp-5633
instead a bundle of papers fell from one
of the veins it depicted the blueprints
for site 202 whether this was a threat
or a message it did not matter to the
personnel at site 202 that was
overseeing the project they commanded
that all the taint team were to return
to base at once while the scp foundation
has ways to combat reality altering
events they also have methods to look at
alternate realities as
scp-5633 is one of these reality vending
anomalies it was decided a much more
in-depth investigation was needed it was
found that in an alternate timeline
[Music]
scp-5633 was a meat processing plant
that suffered a reality alteration the
taint team in that reality had been
trapped in the meat processing plant
only to fight and destroy scp-5633
somehow they were able to disconnect
scp-5633's control on them and the meat
processing plant then overseeing
researchers were able to attach
scp-5633 to various realities that were
different from its own it became
confused and destroyed itself did the
scp foundation of another reality
accidentally send
scp-5633 to this reality it seems that
way so perhaps this version of the scp
foundation could contain it by sending
it to another reality perhaps one that
it didn't have power in it at all the
taint team decided that this was the
course of action they would take they
reviewed the file they had recovered
from the servers of an alternate reality
finding that blood was the correct
sacrifice to give to scp-5633
there was an issue though the humanoid
entity within
scp-5633 had been growing larger along
with its already intense power tests
were being run on the substance found in
the basement as site-202 had been
draining and pumping it into a disposal
and storage laboratory it was found to
be a mixture of blood and dna from over
2 000 different human sources there was
a catastrophic accident with one of the
drainage pipes in site 202 one had been
heated to intense temperatures causing a
potential meltdown of the entire site
on-site security and repair teams moved
in swiftly to combat the issue however
the super-heating and rapid flooding led
to the pipe bursting from shock
splattering everyone in its vicinity
with
scp-5633's fluid the fluid acted almost
as an acid burning away armor clothes
skin and muscle tissue and embedded
itself into the bodies of the victims
they were immediately placed into
temporary containment as at the time it
was unknown what would happen when the
liquid entered the bloodstream as always
tests were performed on the wounded they
found that the entirety of the dna of
those who had been victims of the liquid
was instead reading as scp-56
dna
not their own for the time the victims
seemed fine that was until a week later
when all the victims of this event were
found dead in their cells with cuts on
their wrists and throats logically this
would be the most efficient way to drain
the most amount of blood out of their
bodies in the shortest period of time
the oddest part of this entire ordeal
there was no blood pooled on the ground
whatsoever there were only faintly red
trails of blood up the walls of each
cell that same day
scp-5633 was observed to have grown over
twice in size if the anomaly could
affect people who are not even in the
room what's preventing it from spreading
this liquid to all corners of the earth
and draining all of the human race's
blood into its own mass the taint team
was given a supply of blood to draw
scp-5633 out so that reality anchors
could be placed and it could be sent to
another reality the plan was simple with
dr henry and researcher zeissman placing
the blood bags down and communicating
with the entity firestarter would place
down three portable scranton reality
anchors to contain the entity for a time
the taint team journeyed to scp-5633
this time accompanied by director
streisand the site director believed
that all the deaths caused by
scp-5633 were at her hand as she had
more than enough time to intervene but
didn't this time she was ready to send
this anomaly out of her reality by any
means necessary the brick wall of the
school had gone from a nostalgic
reminder of elementary school to a
nightmare of dead colleagues and the
potential death of reality they were
careful when they entered despite
knowing
scp-5633 was located in the basement
everyone on the team was tense but they
knew they had a mission in mind they
were ready to die in the dark if that
meant everyone could live in the light
with a swift hand dr henry opened the
door to the basement and the three other
members of the taint team followed suit
the basement once again appeared to be
normal the team knew this was a false
sense of security put in place by
scp-5633
so it could coil around them and drain
their blood so it could grow in size and
power the first bag of blood was placed
down and the taint team was met with the
voice of
scp-5633 i like to lie
the ting team was perplexed as the bag
began to be drained of blood what did
scp-5633 lie about another bag was
placed on the ground and firestarter was
commanded to wait my creation was always
inherent your assistance was never
necessary
i told you if you helped me
you would be saved
dr henry in a fit of confusion and rage
threw the rest of the bags to the ground
the only response he was given i am
lying to you
suddenly the hume levels in the room
spike to four thousand the room changed
appearance again
now the taint team was almost drowning
in
scp-5633's liquid they tried to scream
but were only met with mouthfuls of the
disgusting black and red mixture as fast
as the liquid appeared it was gone and
so was the team there was nothing but
silence and the soft sound of slithering
personnel at site 202 realized about one
hour later that something must have gone
wrong with this investigation and
hastily traveled to scp-5633
over 50 members of various mobile task
forces and security teams entered the
school and its basement only to be met
with the disgustingly cruel fate of the
taint team
scp-5633 had reached a height of almost
20 feet dr henry's left arm and nose
were seen floating in the middle of this
mass half of agent firestarter's face
was seen jutting out of what appeared to
be the shoulder of scp-5633
the legs of researchers zeissman were
found at the lower portion of the entity
laying completely still other than
randomly twitching the head of director
streisand was peeking out of the top of
scp-5633
her eyes had been completely replaced
with scp-5633's
veins and she appeared to be crying the
liquid constantly it seemed that
scp-5633 had been influencing events
from the beginning from the death of dr
olek to the pipe explosion to possibly
even creating the entire narrative of
being kicked out of another universe by
an alternate foundation the scp
foundation does know one thing for sure
though
scp-5633 requires a great amount of
blood and it just so happens human
beings have a lot of it now go check out
scp-354 the red pool and frightening
lost ronald reagan vhs tape you must
watch
scp-1981 and
scp-095 for more blood curdling scps
from scp explained